- Catherine, two things,
bravo on whatever was going on in there.
- It is not.
- It is whatever your heart
desires and none of my business.
I will let the fates play their hand.
Second, I think your best come
to the state room with me.
The lunch seems to not sit
well in some people's stomachs.
- What do they want?
- I don't know.
Anytime one of them talks,
the others start yelling.
I made them put that pistols in a bucket.
- It's times like these I'm so glad
you're my key military strategist.
- Tread light my dear, we
will be here if you need us.
- Gentlemen.
(men argue)
Do you have a representative
- Empress, empress, forgive the mob.
We are here to object to your plans
to free the (indistinct).
- Well, there's been a
misunderstanding then.
- Lying German bitch.
(men argue)
- We have no concrete plans.
Only an innocent jape that
I hope you all enjoyed.
- So you are telling
us you have not sought
any further than that.
- Indeed.
- You haven't written down
say 109 page master plan.
- Oddly specific, but no.
- Would you mind
explaining these documents
Ollo has given us?
- They forced it out to me at gunpoint.
- You set me up.
- Nothing personal.
Actually that's probably
a tiny bit untrue.
- A moment, gentlemen.
Are you all right?
You seem a little red.
- I feel a little red.
Everyone wants to kick me right now.
- Fonder that later, act on this now.
You must explain that this is
another of your experiments,
barely sketched out and open to change.
Forgive them their panic for
it seems you wish to unpick
the basis of everything they know,
you don't.
- If you could be quiet,
I would like to explain.
- If you expect them to work for us,
then someone's going to have
to pay them labor costs.
The impact of which no one knows
other than to make our
exports uncompetitive.
- The tax would crush us on core.
- We would figure all that out.
If we open our minds to it,
I know we have the
solution in this very room.
- We will be at the whim of those inbreds.
- Who have rights, who are
human souls with much to give.
- Ah we run their lives, feed, house
instruct them, care for them.
And you tend to want to do
all of that for themselves
and in their downtime
and contribute ideas of genius to Russia.
No offense,
but it don't sound like madness
when you're out of your own.
- Gentlemen, these papers...
- These ones?
(men cheer)
- Give us your word this
will never happen Empress,
and we will of course go back to honoring
and supporting you.
(men argue)
- Gentlemen.
Gentlemen.
(men argue)
Gentlemen listen or I'll shoot you all.
I understand what you've read
this evening seems alarming.
And upon reflection
you are probably right.
I have been a lying German bitch
because I will be freeing
the servants today.
And yes, I yelled that bit for effect
and yes you will pay them a wage
and they will buy goods and services
and create another economy.
And they will strive for
more and invest themselves
in Russia and the filthy
stain of (indistinct)
will be off your hearts.
And unfortunately you may
actually end up richer,
but I actually don't care
whether it costs you,
it will be done.
And there's no amount of threat or spittle
that you can aim at me that
will change my mind on that.
Get used to the future gentleman
because it's coming.
Who threw that?
(men arguing)
Oh God why are they throwing shoes?
- They hate you and I took their guns.
(men yelling)